sie eine junge frau 20 jahre alt lebt in
portugal dort wird sie 2004 im schlaf
überrascht und brutal vergewaltigt der
täter er filmt die tat und verschwindet
bis heute keine spur oder etwa doch bild
kennt die ermittlungsakte der
portugiesischen polizei exklusiv und da
kommt er ins spiel nämlich vieles deutet
darauf hin dass er diese tat begangen
hat christian brückner der mann also der
moment wegen der anderen vergewaltigung
im knast sitzt und vor allen dingen der
tatverdächtige im fall maddie es er soll
maddie mccann entführt und ermordet
haben und jetzt spielt er eine gewaltige
rolle offenbar in einem anderen
vergewaltigung ist voll von dieser hesl
wie bei uns im studio der mann der sich
mit medi mit dem fall am allerbesten
auskennt unser chefreporter kai feldhaus
diese spur ist das eine heiße spur oder
nur in verdacht es könnte zumindest zu
einer heißen spur werden nach
informationen die uns vorliegen erwägt
die staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig
christian brückner wegen dieser
vergewaltigung die 2004 sich in portugal
ereigneten anzuklagen die finale
entscheidung ist da wohl noch nicht
gefallen aber es ist nicht ganz
unwahrscheinlich dass uns das in den
nächsten wochen erwartet du kannst ja
beide ermittlungsakten es gibt noch
einen weiteren pfeil
und du hast diese fälle ja auch
verglichen wo sind die parallelen
tatsächlich lassen sich bei diesen
beiden vergewaltigungen die eine wegen
der christian brückner gesetzt die
andere das ist der fall hesl wie
parallelen finden die nicht von der hand
zu weisen sind zunächst mal ist da die
räumliche und zeitliche ähnlichkeit
beide fälle sind innerhalb weniger
monate passiert beide nur etwa eine
halbe stunde autofahrt entfernt an der
algarve in praia da luz und in praia der
woche dann ist das vorgehen des täters
sehr ähnlich das kann man wohl so sagen
er hat die frauen zu hause überfallen er
war maskiert er hat sie an den haaren
durch die wohnung geschleift und er hat
sich dann an ihnen vergangen
er hat sie mit einem gegenstand
gepeitscht das ist ein fall hazel bbi
soll es eine lederpeitsche gewesen sein
im fall daniel das ist der fall finden
den für den verein setzt ein metallener
gegenstand
und dann hat er beide opfer im anschluss
an die tat auch noch geklaut also hat
mehrere kleingeld und elektro
gegenstände mitgenommen das sind die
ähnlichkeiten die den leuten den
ermittlern da ins auge gefallen ist also
da spricht sozusagen für die ausübung
der tat von christian brückner was
spricht dagegen aktuell das darf man
nicht außer acht lassen es gibt dinge
die nicht zusammen passen da ist einmal
die tatsache dass im fall da ja im das
ist der wegen dem christian brückner
einsetzt der täter eine helle maske
getragen haben soll im fall
hesl b eine dunkle maske das erste opfer
sprich von dunklen augen das zweite
opfer sprich von hellen augen aber ein
punkt der nicht von der hand zu weisen
ist und danach meinem laienhaften
verständnis möglicherweise auch dafür
sorgen könnte dass dieser fall nicht vor
gericht kommt ist die tatsache dass hesl
be
auf dem gesäß ihres peinigers ein tattoo
gesehen hat und nach allem was wir
wissen ich hab nicht persönlich nach
gesehen aber nach dem was man hört hat
christian brückner kein solches tattoo
das könnte möglicherweise vor einer
anklage oder aber einer vor einer
verurteilung hätten heute abend heute
läuft eine spannende doku der fall
maddie mccann es geht also um deinen kai
großen teil kam schnell ist hat das
ganze so lange so intensiv begleitet wie
du wir schauen da mal kurz rein
es gibt glaube ich keinen fall der
weltweit solche schlagzeilen machen
seit dem dritten mai 2007 sie einfach
verschwunden aus dieser ferienanlage an
der portugiesischen algarve alle kennen
die geschichte
[Musik]
die staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig sagt
es gibt einen deutschen vorbestraften
kinderschänder der metal merc entführt
und ermordet
hauptverdächtiger ist der 43 jährige
christian b der derzeit in haft sitzt in
salou amaral hat die ermittlungen im
fall maddie mccann von anfang an geführt
nach seinem verständnis sind kate und
gerry mccann diejenigen die das
verschwinden ihrer tochter verursacht
haben ich habe bis heute keine zweifel
dass eine entführung dort nur simuliert
wurde es gibt mehrere anzeichen dafür
ein fenster von denen niemand sicher
sagen konnte ob es offen oder
geschlossen trotzdem hat man uns erzählt
dass der angebliche anführer dort hinein
und wieder hinaus geklettert ist es gab
fingerabdrücke der mutter des kindes die
zeigen dass sie das fenster geöffnet hat
es waren die einzigen die gefunden dass
gonzalo amaral jetzt ganz klar sagt
christian b das ist nur ein sündenbock
das ist der ideale verdächtige den sie
immer gesucht haben und der hat erfüllt
jetzt mal diese rolle das halte ich für
extrem wertvoll
was passiert wenn ein kind verschwindet
um das zu verstehen habe ich mich mit
dem experten axel petermann verabredet
hätte er vielleicht die eltern als
erstes genauer unter die lupe genommen
lebt denkt fuchs war immer das schiff
das die familie ein harter geborgenheit
ist der zuneigung füreinander da sein
aber der alltag zeigt uns doch genau das
gegenteil und deswegen muss man an eine
solche möglichkeit denken man muss sich
sehr genau mit den spuren des
verschwindens auseinandersetzung um dann
zu sagen ich bin wichtig oder aber ich
muss eine andere version auflegt ich
treffe jetzt in hamburg den anwalt von
christian brückner friedrich fällt schon
denen werde ich jetzt mal dazu befragen
wie geht es ihnen denn im gefängnis das
ist eine blöde frage er sitzt für eine
straftat mehrere jahre in hart von der
er behauptet diese nicht begangen zu
haben und ist an der weltweiten foto
anders kampagne ausgesetzt also wie soll
es weitergehen
die frage die im raum stehen wer ist
verantwortlich für das verschwinden von
madeleine bekennen und wenn man glaubt
jetzt hat man alle meinungen gehört dann
kommt christian runden ecke und erzählt
uns selbst was wir über diesen fall
denkt ihr über die skandalöse
vorverurteilung in seiner in seinem fall
denkt und dieser fall hört einfach nicht
auf
bizarre wendung und wollten zu nehmen
er hört einfach nicht auf dieser fall
schauen sie sich das heute abend
unbedingt an hierbei bild der fall
maddie mccann um 20.15 viertel nach acht
hierbei bild das ist sein größter fall
kai feldhaus bild chefreporter bei uns
im studio passiert da gerade noch was in
diesem fall ist der bewegung drin man
hat seit einigen monaten das gefühl
mensch wir haben dann tatverdächtigen
aber es kommt nicht richtig voran die
ermittlungen im fall maddie sind nicht
abgeschlossen die staatsanwaltschaft
sagt sie sind noch nicht durch sie haben
noch nicht alle sind noch nicht allen
hinweisen nachgegangen ich glaube wir
machen uns kein bild davon wie viele
hinweise da dann eingehen wenn die denn
einmal an die öffentlichkeit treten mit
einem solchen fall aus england aus
deutschland aus portugal das heißt das
dauert das heißt die ermittlungen im
fall maddie mccann sind noch nicht
abgeschlossen aber das darf man nicht
vergessen und das ist ja auch das was
wir gerade an gerissen haben es sind im
zuge der ermittlungen im fall maddie
möglicherweise strafbare dinge
aufgetaucht die christian brückner
ebenfalls anzulasten sind da ist dieser
vergewaltigung von der milliarde sparen
sind aber auch zwei weitere fälle von
sexuellen missbrauchs auch die werden
noch ermittelt und auch da ist bewegung
drin das heißt ich gehe ganz fest davon
aus dass in den nächsten wochen da etwas
passiert was genau das sein wird anklage
oder einstellung das wage ich mal nicht
zu prognostizieren aber es wird etwas
passieren wenn wir gerade in der einer
dokumentation auch gesehen wie viele
theorien ist zu dem verschwinden von
maddie geht du hast es so engmaschig
untersucht so lange recherchiert welche
theorie ist für dich die
wahrscheinlichste ich habe vor langer
zeit aufgehört in diesem fall irgendwas
zu glauben weil ich einfach egal mit wem
man sich unterhält jeder beteiligte hat
eine andere agenda möchte eine
geschichte verkaufen ein buch verkaufen
ein alibi verkaufen sich selbst
reinwaschen andere belasten viele der
beteiligten die jetzt gerade eine rolle
spielen haben als selbst kriminellen
hintergrund das heißt möchten sich
selbst ein bisschen besser dar als sie
sind das heißt es ist sehr sehr
schwierig zu
filtern wem man was glauben kann
deswegen ich verlasse mich auf die
deutsche gerichtsbarkeit ich verlasse
mich darauf dass eine gute deutsche
staatsanwaltschaft das aus ermittelt und
dann sauber auf den tisch legt was da
ist und wenn das dann reicht dann wird
man anklagen und wenn nicht dann wird
man nicht anklagen ich bilde mir da
keinerlei meinung mehr aber bei allem
was kai feldhaus unser chefreporter über
diesen fall maddie weiß hört man
stundenlang gerne zu vielen dank hier im
studio für deinen besuch und mehr eben
heute abend um 20.15 viertel nach acht
der fall mehr die sein größter fall kai
feldhaus größter fall hierbei b